the Hillary standard
the Hillary standard
is what is uh being described it's it's
just a term to describe
the two-tier justice system
probably best
exemplified by the clintons and had the
clintons get away with
I was going to say get away with murder
but maybe that's a little too real you
know I don't listen Hill I don't have
any information that could lead to the
rest of Hillary Clinton please I've got
a family please but the clintons get
away with a whole lot of stuff that the
Republicans never ever would get away
with and even beyond the clintons the
Democrats get away with a whole lot of
stuff that the Republicans would never
ever get away with and then the
Democrats have the temerity to accuse
Republicans of doing exactly the sort of
thing that they have been doing for
years you saw this especially a couple
of days ago with Jamie Raskin Democrat
member of Congress who goes on CBS and
he doubles down on the Biden line that
the Republicans and they're not they're
no longer just the loyal opposition the
Republicans they're no longer just bad
for the country they're downright
fascists
two of the Hallmarks of a fascist
political party are one they don't
accept the results of elections that
don't go their way and two they Embrace
political violence and I think that's
why President Biden was right to sound
the alarm this week about these
continuing attacks on our constitutional
order from the outside by Donald Trump
and his movement
two Hallmarks of fascism again I had the
same reaction that I had when the White
House Press Secretary used that word I
had the same reaction that I had when
Biden used that word none of these
people certainly including Jamie Raskin
have ever read or really even ever heard
of the doctrine of fascism that was
written by Mussolini and the philosopher
Giovanni Gentile that describes what
fascism is none of these people have
ever read the early fascist manifestos
that came earlier they don't know any of
this stuff okay they're just they're not
using fascism to refer to an actual
political movement an Italian political
movement that really flourished in the
20th century they're they're just using
fascism to mean something I don't like
okay there are plenty of political
movements that push political violence
and don't accept the results of
elections okay the Communists have done
that there have been liberals who have
done that they're the Democratic Party
in the United States has certainly done
that okay
who does that sound like not accepting
the results of elections and peddling
political violence but does it maybe
sound like the party that didn't accept
the results of the 2000 election or the
party that hasn't accepted the results
of the 2016 election or the party that
didn't accept the results of the 2018
Georgia gubernatorial election or on the
political violence front maybe the party
that encouraged political violence for
eight months led by BLM and antifa or
maybe the party where the sitting vice
president the current vice president
right now bailed out the rioters in
Minneapolis or maybe the party that
called for for violent Democrats and
Libs to go out and harass Republicans in
public and at their homes where their
children sleep does it sound like them
sure sounds like them to me and
thankfully finally finally
Peter Ducey the one kind of conservative
reporter in the White House Press pool
asked the press secretary Kareem
Jean-Pierre about this because Korean
Jean-Pierre
has referred to multiple elections that
Republicans won
and stolen Justin trying to understand
the new attention on the mag of
Republicans you tweeted
stole an election I was waiting Peter
when you were going to ask me that
question well here we go you tweeted
Trump's stolen election you tweeted
Brian Kemp stole an election if denying
election results is Extreme now yep wow
so let's let's be really clear that that
comparison that you made is just
ridiculous I have been I have been well
you're asking me you're asking me a
question let me answer it
ridiculous I was I was talking
specifically at that time of what was
happening with voting rights and the
what was in danger of voting rights
that's what I was speaking to at the
time hold on before we get into the this
fake argument the the thing that sounds
like an argument that she's trying to
make
just listen to those words there at the
she goes hold on hold on no it's
ridiculous it's ridiculous at the time
okay what I was talking about was Voting
Rights
and what was happening
voting rights what does I don't even
know what the semantic value of that of
those phrases are
you said green Jean-Pierre you said that
the 2016 election was stolen and the
2018 election was stolen
so yeah I guess that has to do with
voting rights if the if the election is
stolen then that undermines voting
rights
sure
but you
all of that is in service of the claim
that the election was stolen but now
you're saying that anyone who claims the
election is stolen is a fascist and a
threat to democracy but you not only
your political party 20 years ago you
yourself have done that within the last
four years
and her her actual response to this
because you you heard her try to just
cut off Peter Ducey oh yeah here we go I
knew you'd ask about this yeah you knew
he would ask about this because it shows
your rank hypocrisy and how disingenuous
you are in your argument about fascism
and a threat to democracy
but she says no it's okay it's
ridiculous it's ridiculous
because it's not fascism when I do it
that's what the Democrats are saying
yeah I the thing that I'm accusing
Republicans of doing we have done and
continued to do but it's bad when they
do it and it's good when we do it
that's what they mean
if the Republicans are any threat to
democracy which which we're not but if
we were the Democrats would be at least
as much of a threat to democracy and
actually much more of a threat of
democracy because they have undermined
and delegitimized more elections
if the Republicans are a threat to
democracy because of the Republican
political violence the Democrats are
much much more of a threat to democracy
because Democrats have engaged in much
much more almost infinitely more
political violence
and the Republicans have
so what does this mean for democracy
it is a kind of threat to democracy
in the sense that if if neither side
believes that the elections are fair or
legitimate
then we do then we do not have a
functioning democracy if you don't have
faith that the will of the voters is
being in some way some at least mostly
accurately reflected in the polls then
you don't have a democracy and the
Democrats know that they're just saying
okay we're the only ones who are going
to question it because we're going to
remain in power what they are saying
effectively is and Joe Biden said this
almost word for word if you vote for the
other party in our two-party system
you're a threat to democracy that means
we don't have a two-party system anymore
that means that by our democracy they
mean a totalitarian one-party government
if you're if you're not legitimately
allowed to vote for the other party then
you don't have a two-party system and
you don't have a democracy hello melores
hello my ladies go to established
titles.com slash Knowles you have to do
it this is your opportunity to earn the
title of Lord or lady and gain the
respect you deserve all you need is a
one square foot plot of land in Scotland
established titles can make it happen
it's a Project based on an historic
Scottish custom where landowners are
referred to as lairds or Lords and
Ladies in English in your title pack you
will will be bestowed with at least one
square foot of dedicated land on a
private estate in edelston Scotland plus
an official certificate with a Crest
your certificate features a unique plot
Number with which you can see the exact
location of your land title packs from
established titles are a fun and unique
gift for any occasion there are even
couple packs because you don't want to
be a Lord and then your wife isn't a
lady or vice versa so you can you can
get that for the special someone in your
life with your certificate you can
officially add the prefix of Lord or
lady to your credit cards your plane
tickets even your dating profiles plus
established titles commits to preserving
The Woodlands not only in Scotland but
around the world they have Partnerships
with global Charities such as one tree
planted and trees for the future to help
with our afforestation efforts and for
every order they receive a tree is
planted do it right now established
titles told me that the first 200 people
purchasing a title pack using my
exclusive link will receive a plot
within a few walking minutes of mine
that's right so we can be lards and
ladies together depending on how many of
you want to become a large or lady we
can build our own kingdom established
titles is running a massive sale right
now plus if you use my code knows you
get an additional 10 off go to
established titles.com to get your gift
now and help support the channel I'm so
glad that you liked that clip now if you
want to get more Clips more
notifications you got to ring the bell
subscribe take us from 1 million
subscribers to 1 billion that's right we
can do it we need your help ring that
Bell we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]